[Musique]
pour beaucoup d'entre nous c'est du déjà
vu
vous arpentez une ville inconnue et
après deux ou trois coins de rue vous
êtes perdus
si votre sens de l'orientation fait
défaut c'est peut-être qu'il ne s'est
pas entraîné au bon endroit des
chercheurs européens ont étudié les
liens entre notre capacité à nous situer
dans l'espace et notre lieu d'origine il
s'avère que l'endroit où on a grandi
façonne notre capacité à nous orienter
en gros on retrouve plus facilement son
chemin si on est de la campagne plutôt
que de la ville
les chercheurs ont tiré ses conclusions
d'un jeu vidéo dans sea hero Quest les
joueurs doivent d'abord étudier un plan
puis naviguer à travers cet espace le
jeu a été créé pour aider les médecins à
évaluer la perte d'orientation spatiale
chez leur patient qui peut être un
symptôme précoce de maladie cognitives
comme l'Alzheimer
l'étude porte sur les données de près de
400 000 participants
issus de 38 pays en s'inscrivant les
joueurs fournissaient des informations
sur leurs origines à savoir s'ils
avaient grandi en ville ou pas et dans
quel pays
conclusion ceux qui ont grandi à la
campagne se repèrent mieux dans un
environnement inconnu que ceux qui
viennent d'un milieu urbain
les chercheurs avancent une explication
à la campagne on est plus souvent
acteurs de ces déplacements on conduit
soi-même sa voiture par exemple sont de
plus grandes distances
alors qu'en ville on peut utiliser les
transports en commun pour se rendre du
point A au point B sont toujours
surveiller le chemin emprunté
[Musique]
la différence ville campagne et
particulièrement marquée si on est
originaire d'une ville quadrillée
n'importe quel touriste vous le dira on
retrouve plus facilement son chemin dans
un endroit comme Montréal ou Toronto
qu'à Paris ou à Prague
les chercheurs ont classé les
principales villes des pays d'origine
des participants selon leur niveau
d'organisation spatiale ce qu'ils
appellent l'entropie plus l'endroit où
on a vécu était désordonné mieux en se
situe dans un environnement complexe par
conséquent dans les pays où les villes
sont moins compliquées en naviguer
l'écart entre citadins et ruraux en
matière de sens de l'orientation et plus
grand
c'est le cas chez nous au Canada ou les
plans des rues sont en général plutôt
simple
[Musique]
notre origine géographique n'est pas le
seul facteur qui influe sur notre sens
d'orientation plus on est âgé moins on
se repère facilement
et ce n'est pas un mythe les femmes
s'orientent moins bien que les hommes
mais les chercheurs ont mis en relation
cette distinction avec un indice
d'égalité homme-femme le gender gap
index et bien dans les pays où hommes et
femmes sont plus égaux ces différences
s'estompent jusqu'à quasiment
disparaître comme un Scandinavie la
disparité homme-femme dans l'orientation
serait donc surtout culturel
mais que penser de l'impact des GPS sur
notre capacité à nous orienter
aujourd'hui rien de plus facile que de
retrouver son chemin
[Musique]
quel effet ça sur notre sens de
l'orientation ce n'est pas encore clair
disent les chercheurs dans certains cas
c'est une béquille alors que dans
d'autres c'est une invitation à
s'aventurer plus loin